while the it movies are absolutely
frightening they're also filled with a
number of errors that are hard to ignore
so what exactly did the filmmakers get
wrong try to avoid the dead lights as we
look for all the big mistakes in the it
movies the first installment of Andy
musky at ease it adaptation includes a
number of Stephen King multiverse Easter
eggs one of them is a bright green lego
turtle handled by young build em bro
played by Jada Martell which shatters
when it drops on the floor in King's
novel the turtle Mattern is the creator
of the known universe and the spiritual
foil of Pennywise the clown the turtle
helps the novel's central group of
protagonists who call themselves the
losers hang out a loser too but in 1989
when it chapter 1 takes place not all of
those green Lego shades were
commercially available the dark green
bricks that make up most of the turtles
body weren't on the market until around
1996 and the lime green bricks used as
accents weren't available until the
early 2000s there are a number of errors
in both hit movies that shatter the
illusion we're in Derry Maine instead we
often get a Canadian vibe which is
understandable since the movies were
primarily shot in Canada still there are
some parts where the production team
overlooked crucial details that gave
away that the characters were not in New
England and were in fact a bit further
north
for example the Derry town square
features a huge War Memorial there are
of course war memorials all over the
United States but we know this one's
Canadian because part of the inscription
honors the man who died for king and
country in the Great War considering
that America was founded in a rebellion
of the British monarchy and has never
had a king
American War memorabilia wouldn't have
that particular phrase anywhere another
clue that were not where the movie
claims to be involves the police cars
that appear in the films while audiences
unfamiliar with Maine may not see
anything amiss about the flashing red
and blue lights at the police cars those
familiar with the region would know that
Maine law enforcement vehicles only have
blue lights making the red a dead
giveaway that we're in a different place
than we think then at the end of it
chapter 2 when all is set right by the
adult losers the camera pans over the
town of Derry which is back to its
idyllic Maine setting and free of the
threat of child eating monsters however
there's still one problem a sign for the
exclusively Canadian real estate company
Royal LePage is visible on one of the
buildings which gives away the fact that
this isn't Maine at all or even the
United States the character of Stanley
URIs played by Wyatt Olaf is the son of
the town rabbi who we meet in it chapter
one preparing Stan for his upcoming Bar
Mitzvah in one scene after a frustrated
Stan finishes reading from the Torah he
shuts the book and walks off but when he
closes the book we can see that it is
upside down whoever placed the book in
front of Stan on the set either didn't
know or forgot that Hebrew is read from
right to left
not left-to-right like English which
means that the letters on the cover
should have been to Stan's right not his
left at least when Stan later returns
the book to the shelf in his father's
office he corrects this error and places
it on the Shelf right-side up
when young beverly played by sophia
Lillis runs into the rest of the losers
Club in the pharmacy in it chapter 1
she's trying to figure out which tampons
to buy while the boys are gathering
first aid supplies in order to treat
Ben's injuries after his run-in with
Henry Bowers everyone is incredibly
awkward with each other especially
Beverly since she wants to keep her
period a secret from the boys during
this scene we see a number of Olay
skincare products on a shelf near the
kids the only problem is in 1989 the
brand was called Oil of Olay
it didn't get rebranded into Olay until
1999 you can also see dial and Ivory
soap sporting their modern-day packaging
in the pharmacy scenes along with
Covidien curity bandages which didn't go
by that name until 2007 in it chapter
one Eddie's mother Sonya played by Molly
Atkinson is an enthusiastic consumer of
the snack Swedes brand
mrs. fresh Lee's delicious deals from
oatmeal cream pie cookies to iced honey
buns these treats dominate Eddie's
pantry and when the losers are over at
Eddie's house he tells them to leave
those alone take everything but the
delicious deal guys
the only problem is mrs. fresh Lee's
brand wasn't established until 1994 a
good four years after it chapter one
takes place in addition the packaging on
Sonja's snacks is the same design you
can find in stores today when we meet
Beverly Marsh in it chapter 1 the poor
girl is getting bullied from all sides
her
mother is abusive and the girls at
school torments her mercilessly shaming
her because she kissed a boy in the
school play
and teasing her because she's poor
eventually Beverly tries to hide from
the Mean Girls in the bathroom
but her plan backfires when the girls
find her they dump a bunch of wet
garbage into her toilet stall
fortunately Beverly has her backpack
which she uses to block most of the gunk
raining down on her but just moments
later when she runs into Ben outside her
backpack is totally clean and totally
dry the losers Club aren't only battling
a vicious clown creature they also have
a group of human enemies in the form of
sadistic bully Henry Bowers played by
Nicholas Hamilton and his gang one day
Bowers and his crew of goons chase
homeschooled orphan Mike Hanlon played
by chosen Jacobs into the Barrens where
the losers hang out and a rock fight
ensues this is the first time the rest
of the losers meet Mike who makes their
lucky number seven but an unfortunate
continuity error occurs when Henry's
friend belch begins bleeding before
Beverly's Rock actually makes contact
with his head what's more the rock
catches him on the side of his baseball
cap not across the bridge of his nose
where the injury mysteriously appears
Ritchie trashmouth Tozier played by Finn
wolf Hardin is a kid who's constantly
making snarky quips and his friends are
constantly asking him to shut his
piehole throughout both hit movies many
of Ritchie's comments come in the form
of pointed insults such as the rock
fight between the losers and Henry
Bowers gang when Ritchie yells but while
the term mullet was first coined in 1967
School Hand Luke it didn't actually
enter popular usage until after the 1994
Beastie Boys song mullet egg since the
first installment of it takes place in
1989 Ritchie's comment has no context
for that time period even though it does
for modern-day viewers after the losers
Club think they've defeated Pennywise at
the end of it chapter one
bill still isn't 100% convinced that the
ordeal is over
he asks everyone to swear that if
Pennywise is still alive they'll all
return to Derry to help him defeat it if
it isn't dead
if it ever comes back
we'll come back to to seal their vow to
one another bill uses a broken piece of
glass to cut everybody's palms so that
they can make a blood oath promising
that they'll all come together again if
they need to while this is a powerful
and somber moment symbolizing the
transition of the losers from childhood
to adulthood it is slightly marred by
another continuity error although the
shard of glass bill uses to cut the
losers hands has blood on it after the
first few cuts the blood miraculously
disappears after he cuts Mike's hand and
stays strangely clean for the rest of
the ritual although it chapter one takes
place entirely in 1989 chapter two flips
between 1989 and 2019 as the losers Club
returns dairy to end the battle between
the town and Pennywise once and for all
one of the flashbacks to 1989 features a
key scene at the video game arcade
between Richie Tozier and another boy
which suggests Richie might be gay the
scene turns out to be doubly important
when years later a video game token ends
up being the talisman the adult Richie
played by Bill Hader uses for the ritual
of chud which aims to destroy Pennywise
unfortunately there's a huge gap to go
along with these important events in the
background of the arcade we can see the
game's Mortal Kombat and Mortal Kombat 2
however the Mortal Kombat games were
released in 1992 in 1993 respectively
making it impossible for them to have
been in an arcade in 1989 in it chapter
1 Pennywise kidnaps young Beverly and
hypnotizes her with dead lights storing
her in a kind of stasis in the sewer
along with all the other dead and
missing children of Derry the rest of
the losers Club go in to rescue her
using the entrance in the haunted house
on niebolt Street while we never see how
the losers get from the sewers to the
field where they sealed their blood oath
in Chapter 1 a flashback in it chapter 2
shows Beverly pushing her bike through
Derry alongside the rest of the losers
immediately after the showdown before
any of them go home
however since she was kidnapped she
shouldn't have had a bike at all it's
possible she could have borrowed one
after leaving niebolt Street but in that
case one of the other losers should have
been missing a bike instead of each of
them having their own just because the
losers Club grew up that doesn't mean
their childhood bullies didn't follow
them into adulthood
in it chapter 2 the
- Henry Bowers played by teach grant
escapes from the institution for the
criminally insane where he's been living
since taking the fall for all of penny
wisest murders back in 1989 on the
clown's orders Henry goes after the
surviving losers stabbing Eddy played by
James ransom straight through the cheek
knowing that they can't halt the mission
Eddy and Beverly played as an adult by
Jessica Chastain patches face up then
proceeded down into the sewers to finish
Pennywise but the emotional tension is
interrupted when Eddy's bandage briefly
flips from one side of his face to the
other this can happen when the negative
gets reversed but it should have been an
easy thing to catch and fix for the
adult losers to vanquish penny wise Mike
played by Isaiah Mustafa determines that
they need to perform the ritual of
shutdown and Pennywise is feeding layer
but in order to fully complete the
ritual each loser must bring a token
that was significant to them during the
summer when they faced the monster as
children in 1989 Eddy's token is his
asthma inhaler Ritchie's as a video game
token Bin's is the page of his yearbook
that only Beverly signed Bev's is the
postcard poem that Ben wrote her and
bills is the paper boat that he made for
his little brother but somehow even
after the losers get fully immersed in
the murky sewer water the paper tokens
belonging to Bev Ben and Bill are still
completely dry when they toss them into
the fire the paper boat may still have
been safe due to the wax coating bill
applied on it for Georgie at the
beginning of the first film but the
postcard in the yearbook page should
have been sopping wet check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more Lube or videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]